♫ Here right now with
your boy, imagine this
♫ Keepin' it live with Skeewiff
♫ Check one two
♫ Is you listening
♫ We gonna give it to them
right here, right now, baby
♫ Y'all ready
♫ When they ask me why,
when they ask me why
♫ It's 'cause I love it,
it's 'cause I love it
♫ Yo, we going out of control
♫ We going out of this world, come on, hey
♫ When they ask me why,
when they ask me why
♫ It's 'cause I love it,
it's 'cause I love it
♫ Hey yo, we going out of control
♫ Come on, I make you bounce so hard
♫ Baby, I just can't help myself
♫ Can't help it, no I can't help it
♫ No
♫ I make you bounce so hard
♫ I can't help it
♫ Uh-huh
♫ From the first time I felt it
♫ To the last time I dealt it
♫ Say what
♫ Trains change but the
vibes's still the same
♫ Everywhere I bless 'em
with the flow they go insane
♫ Yup, hey, it's simple and plain
♫ And if you lend me your ear,
well, I'm willing to explain
♫ Come on, through the thick and thin
♫ Through the high and low,
through the lefts and rights
♫ Or the back and forth, from
the lock to the open doors
♫ To the way that we rock
the block and stay raw
♫ I put the hard to the
core while I even the score
♫ Making war while they
break it down on the floor
♫ Got 'em yelling out
♫ Hardcore, give me more,
give me more, give me more
♫ When they ask me why,
when they ask me why
♫ It's 'cause I love it,
it's 'cause I love it
♫ Yo, we going out of control
♫ We going out of this world
♫ Come on, hey
♫ When they ask me why,
when they ask me why
♫ It's 'cause I love it,
it's 'cause I love it
♫ Hey yo, we going out of control
♫ Come on, I make you bounce so hard
♫ Baby, I just can't help myself
♫ I love it, yes I love it
♫ Yeah
♫ From the way that the DJ cut it
♫ All the way to the
cats who break it down
♫ And the girls who only
came here to strut it
♫ Strut it
♫ Turn it up move while Adam here
♫ Treat it like you on top
of the world, man of the year
♫ Tear the roof off,
the vibe, the atmosphere
♫ Got you feeling like your
ready to leave the stratosphere
♫ We do it all night, we do it all night
♫ Spread love in this mother
♫ Get you feeling all right
♫ We do it all day, we do it all day
♫ 'Cause there ain't no
stopping 'til we find a way
♫ Come on
♫ Working all the time
♫ Working all the time,
but it don't feel like work
♫ When you're having a good time
♫ So go ahead, let me
see you shake your behind
♫ 'Cause I got the stuff
that can blow your mind
♫ When they ask me why,
when they ask me why
♫ It's 'cause I love it,
it's 'cause I love it
♫ Yo, we going out of control
♫ We going out of this world, come on, hey
♫ When they ask me why,
when they ask me why
♫ It's 'cause I love it,
it's 'cause I love it
♫ Hey yo, we going out of control
♫ Come on, I make you bounce so hard
♫ Baby, I just can't help myself
(upbeat funk music)
♫ When they ask me why,
when they ask me why
♫ It's 'cause I love it,
it's 'cause I love it
♫ Hey yo, we going out of control
♫ Come on, I make you bounce so hard
♫ Baby, I just can't help myself ♫